[Music]
if frontline healthcare workers have
been our superheroes during the
coronavirus
hospitals and healthcare facilities have
been the back case
constructing new hospital wings or new
buildings cost
hundreds of millions of dollars and can
take years
they're designed and built with the
expectation of being able to last for
decades
and with the coronavirus we're learning
just how big a role they play
in the fight
hospitals were always designed to treat
the ill
but battling cobit 19 over the last
seven months has pushed many
to their limit the assumption that if
you get sick that we're going to have a
hospital bed for you
is a false assumption across the country
surges and cases have forced hospitals
like chicago's rush university medical
center
to spring into action the first thing we
did was create a command
center to bring together
all the different people in the
organization to represent all the
potential landmines
and unmet needs that we would have dr
omar latif
is president and ceo at rush then
we just took a giant board and wrote
down how do we change physically this
hospital so that we can take care of
larger numbers of people
that process actually started eight
years ago
long before the pandemic when rush added
a new wing
to their hospital when you build
something for the future of health care
you try to build something that has
flexibility or agility in it
we built an 830 000 square foot
building in the city that has the
ability to change air flows the ability
to
double rooms the ability to surge to 133
percent its capacity
it's pretty intensive former nurse
brenda smith
is a healthcare designer with perkins
and will the architectural firm that
worked on the rush project
we have phases where we first are trying
to create sort of a list of all of the
kinds of functional spaces that they
need you look at the flow
of people both staff and patients and
you look at the flow of kind of
equipment and all the things that are
required to operate
in that space and some of that's been
rethought with covet as well
future design must also consider
frontline healthcare workers
many of whom had to make hospitals their
home
people stay sometimes 15 hours 20 hours
24 hours 36 hours with little breaks in
between
we really need to make sure that we
provide areas where they can rest
something else to consider emergency
conversions
transforming everything from city parks
to convention centers
you know we had to move very fast back
in april
jason sharor director of health with hks
took on the task of converting detroit's
convention center
we have to convert non-health buildings
into health buildings that's where i
think we begin to
perhaps look at a diminishing standard
of care
which may not give us the best outcomes
still the task of repurposing spaces
is nothing new they did temporary
hospitals in the 1918 pandemic
historian jeannie kasaki says the flu
presented its own challenges
and solutions most of the hospitals are
built along the old version the big open
wards
and they are rapidly overwhelmed after
the pandemic there's a real
shift to having smaller rooms and
one patient per room or what they call
one unit
or one disease so they could have three
patients with the same disease
and they would put them in the same room
if today's healthcare architects learn
anything from their 20th century peers
it will be to take the lessons of this
pandemic forward
by improving our ability to respond to
the next one
so the primer here the big lesson is
i think the big lesson is the hospitals
must be designed to respond more rapidly
we're talking days and weeks
not months and years we need to be
thinking about creating
uh pandemic preparedness in terms of
flexibility schedule and
and the ability to compartmentalize
infectious
hot spots within hospitals in the future
it's going to be very important for
hospitals to be able to maintain
you know normal services during a crisis
and it's a constant learning process
architects designers healthcare workers
tweaking
you know in real time and it's global i
mean peers are sharing all over the map
including uh folks here in the united
states looking at their peers in
asia for help because they've had some
really unique design elements
because you don't know when the next
pandemic happens whether it's a year or
a hundred years right and if you haven't
seen something that someone else has
no way to prepare for it ahead great
story michelle thank you